the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I've got a little list of things I'm
hoping to do today I'll begin with a few
final words about saddle points the
reason I'm interested in saddle points
is when we get to this deep learning
direction you know that the big step
there is finding a minimum of the cost
total cost function and gradient descent
which will certainly discuss is the
usual method or stochastic radius
gradient descent and all kinds of issues
arise what happens if you have a saddle
point that's or or degenerate and
minimum all these possibilities and the
understanding of deep learning is is
focusing more and more on what does that
gradient descent algorithm produce so I
just thought saddle minima and Maxima we
know about saddle points are kind of a
little hazy er right so so what this is
a perfect example and I'll just say a
few more words about it then I want to
talk about the lab three that I boldly
posted on the on stellar and also about
projects just to get you get us thinking
about those and then and then my real
math topic for today and this week is
basic ideas of statistics
particularly the covariance matrix I'm
sure you've met mean and variance those
are the most used words and we'll use
them again but then I want to go on to
covariance okay so that's what's coming
today a few words on saddle points a lot
of words about the lab and anything you
can want to ask about projects and then
some basic statistics okay
saddle point so the example I'm taking
is this Rayleigh quotient and I'm taking
a simple matrix s I might as well take a
diagonal matrix because I can I it's
symmetric of course and any symmetric
matrix I could just change variables by
a Q matrix and orthogonal matrix to get
to something like that and then the X
we're in 3d so we got a sort of
manageable size here and the X vector is
UVW so this is the quotient X transpose
X you see is just exactly 5u Squared's 3
v Squared's and 1 w squared and I divide
by the length to normalize things so
what are the main facts that we know
with that I'm not going to prove but
what are the main facts what's the
maximum value of R what's the minimum
value of R of that function and is there
a saddle point so saddle up are ok
what's the maximum value how large could
you make that ratio capital R I just
think you know this isn't a standard
topic in 1806 but it with an example
like this you'll see the whole point
okay so how large could I make R
go ahead and say it Sigma 1 and but what
is it here let's just do with these
numbers how big can I make that ratio or
and and what choice of uvw makes it big
so how big I can get it is 5 that that
ratio can't be more than 5 you see it
would be 5 well how do I get to 5
maximum of R is 5 and what is the UVW
that that so I'll say at what choice of
uvw would give us 5 here you you see it
immediately 1 0 0 and what about the
minimum of our the minimum of this ratio
how do I make that ratio small well I
put I load stuff onto W instead of
loading it up on to you right it's just
it's clear so what is the minimum value
of our 1 because I'll load everything
into W so the minimum value will be 1
and that'll be at the vector 0 0 1 I've
loaded everything there and then at the
point of this short discussion is is
there another place where the
derivatives first derivatives of AR are
all 0 that's that's where of course the
first derivatives are are 0 at the max
at the min but we also we have we have 3
variables here and we're going to find
the third point and what is that point
you probably guess and what will be the
saddle value so so you have to see some
kind of a surface that that I guess what
are we in 4d so we have we have vectors
we have base base coordinates UVW and r
goes vertically and we plot that surface
and we don't really understand it unless
we think a lot about it which we haven't
but
we can pretty well guess what's what and
so what do you think is the saddle value
and where is it going to be reached
everybody's going to tell me correctly
saddle value would be three at this
middle point okay and and these what are
these three with respect to the matrix
they're its eigenvectors what are these
three numbers with respect to the matrix
they're its eigenvalues it's just like
that's why that Rayleigh quotient is
such an important function it's kind of
a messy function if you take its
derivative you know you've got to use
the quotient rule or or use the groans
multiplier to make it that's the way to
make it more manageable but it's kind of
messy but the results could not be
better the the values there are the
eigenvalues on these and the places
where you reach them are the
eigenvectors and so the max is the most
important so this is that's Sigma one
here's Sigma three or let lambda and
Sigma because the matrix is symmetric
positive-definite and here in the middle
is Sigma 2 and if we want to compute
eigenvalues and eigenvectors getting the
largest one or the smallest one is a lot
quicker and in general than getting
these ones in the middle you have to you
know use good codes and and pay
attention to computing their saddle
point values so is there anything nice I
can do with saddle points how does how
could one how does one think about
saddle points
so again saddle point is defined by
first
derivatives equal zero that's and the
second derivatives okay so that's that's
a matron here's a vector the gradient
vector there two rivers respect to you
that a respective V in the RDW just a
vector and they're all all those
components are 0 the the gradient vector
is 0 but what about second derivatives
well that's getting more they're a lot
there nine of those now because I've got
are you you second derivative with
respect to you second and then but I've
got mixed derivative second derivative
of R with respect to do you DV so I have
a three by three matrix
fortunately that matrix is symmetric
because we have we're blessed by that
wonderful fact that the derivative with
respect to U and then V is the same as V
and then you so we get a symmetric
matrix and it's well I won't write it
down but it's it's going to have a you
know will it's got there is a maximum
minimum and and saddled information
built in here's this one additional sort
that I want to communicate about saddle
points because it's really nice to
somehow get back to maxima and minima so
the idea of us this idea for a saddle
point is to be able to write it as the
maximum of a minimum in a way yeah so
let me do that and then I'm all done
okay
so I'm going to say that lambda to that
value is the maximum of over something
of the minimum over something of
extremes of our of our function okay
that's nice I have to tell you what
you're maximizing over and what you're
minimizing over but that's the idea is
that one way to get into the middle
middle of place there where the saddles
are sitting is to have a maximum of a
minimum and that leads this what I'm
about to complete here would lead you
for example very quickly to the
interlacing theorem that I spoke about
for for eigen values or and for singular
values of when you perturb s or when you
throw away a row and column of s you you
the eigen values go in between that is
the kind of conclusion that this max-min
stuff is set up to produce so here let
me just tell you what it would be I'm
aiming to get lambda to okay so I'm
gonna take a maximum over to be a two
dimensional spaces sub subspaces
subspaces of r3 we're in 3d so I'm you
can see that sort of like two
dimensional spaces let me give that
subspace a name like V ah yeah that'll
do cat V everybody can see that that's a
caffee and then this will be the minimum
ovaries so it's um it's kind of tricky
so I take any subspace that's
two-dimensional and I'll take one in a
moment and I'll figure out the minimum
suppose I take the subspace V whose men
which is spanned by the first two it's
supposed to be a 2d subspace spanned by
the first suppose I try example example
the span of 1 0 0 and 0 1 0 in other
words all vectors u v 0 that's a 2d
space ok what is the minimum of that
Rayleigh quotient over that two
dimensional space so now I'm taking a
minimum I don't have to think about
saddle points so I'm in all so I'm
looking at the same but I've but W is 0
now everybody sees that that I've
squeezed it down to 2d so W is 0 what so
what is the minimum now so so this this
thing would become for this space would
become the 5 u squared and the 3 V
squared over the u squared plus the B
squared
but the W is 0 so what's the minimum of
that 3 3 ok
the minimum is 3 for this particular
space let me call it V special that for
that particular space the minimum is 3
correct everybody sees that because I
just have U and V to play with the 5 and
the 3 so if I put everything into V I
get to the 3 and now I take the maximum
so so I've learned that this so the
maximum is at least 3 because this
particular choice of V gave me the
answer 3 and now I'm taking the maximum
over all possible 2d spaces and
certainly I got three for one of the
possible spaces of V and I might get
higher than three for some other one but
actually I don't
the truth is that the this turns out to
be three which is of course exactly what
we wanted so I'm saying that this
particular two dimensional space the
minimum of over that minimum the minimum
there is three and now I maximize over
all others and and so the idea is that
for any other one the minimum value will
be below three and therefore when I go
for the max of the mins I get three so I
just repeat that and then be quiet about
this whole subject so it's a maximum
over subspaces
of a minimum of the Rayleigh quotient if
that subspace is exactly the perfect
choice this one I get the value three
and I'm claiming that's the biggest
value I can get because if I pick any
other subspace
what if I pick the subspace that suppose
suppose another V would be all vectors
0vw
what would be the minimum what would I
get for the minimum of this thing but
now W is in the picture and U is not in
the picture what would I get for the
minimum there what I'd get one the
minimum would be when I put everything
into W and I got one and then when I
take the max it's not a winner it's
thrown out the winner will be the that
space and the three so I guess I'm
hoping that you sort of see in this
small example that you can express this
middle saddle value as it's reasonable
think of it as a maximum in some
directions and a minimum
another think of the well try to think
of some surface which is going up in
some directions so it's a minimum in
those directions and it's going down in
other direction so it's a max in those
directions and Salo points just perched
in there at that right at that place at
the saddle point you know if you're like
hiking from here to California or
something there's going you're going to
pass a saddle point actually you see it
on them at the Mass Pike is an amazing
little little sign I don't know if
you've noticed it if you drive west on
the Mass Pike pretty far or west of
Boston there's a little sign saying
telling you the altitude or elevation
whatever and it says there this is the
highest point until you reach the
Rockies basically that's it like okay
Midwest is pretty flat right and because
that's a long way away you don't think
of Massachusetts as like really in the
big league with high spots but there it
is
it's the highest one until you get and I
think it tells you where where the next
one will be in Colorado anyway those
highest points are tend to be saddles
the very very highest point where is
that in Alaska or somewhere that that's
a max of course by definition but there
are a lot of saddle points in in other
places and those would be Maxima of
minima or minima Maxima good I'm
stopping there we might see this again
when we start a gradient descent but at
least because saddle points don't come
up much in teaching calculus I thought
that was good okay
second point is models lab 3 and
projects anything you'd like to ask
about projects so please this is your
chance to ask you could also ask by
email you if you have a suggested or
idea for a project let me encourage you
or a team to work on it or just yourself
and if you want to think ok shall I get
some feedback of does this sound
sensible any suggestions send me an
email
yeah I'll be happy to because I'm a
total beginner here too when I created
this lab 3 I was like desperate not for
model 1 for model 1 have you looked at
the it's online it's it's reached
stellar
it's only one printed page the people
had a look at this
so I'll just repeat quickly model 1 is
is a example where of overfitting and
and what's going on with model 1 so
model one says take five would be enough
but I probably said 10 or something so
I'll make it six points and put
approximate put a curve through them so
if you put a curve and the curve is
going to be a polynomial so we're going
to fit it fit by by polynomial everybody
knows polynomial is C naught plus C 1 X
plus whatever C K X to the K let's say
okay
for K equals zero well I don't know if I
even asked zero that would be the best
straight line that would be run along
the average k equal to one that would be
a straight line fit and you would
compute that by these squares because of
course our no straight line is going to
go through all the points you're going
to have some error by least squares to
would be fitting by a parabola again
you'll have some error but smaller since
parabolas include straight lines so you
can only reduce total sum of squares
error by going to degree 2 degree 3 and
up to how many points so we take 1 2 let
me just use the same letter I've used
here probably of oh well the M M is the
number of points but M varies between
one point I guess and and probably an
end point yeah or maybe K up to up to up
to up to six let's say okay and I want
to make a comment about six no five
would do it won't 5 degree 5 will fit
the six points that we've got six points
here but if I stop a degree five I was
better there because degree 5 polynomial
also has a constant term so it really
has six coefficients so there's a degree
there's a 1 degree 5 polynomial with six
numbers six coefficients that goes
through those six points and it so it's
a perfect fit
that would be exact fit of the data so
here's the data create a polynomial of
degree 5 that goes through those points
exactly and look at the result and what
what would you see
if you look at the result would it be
smooth of course it's a polynomial would
it be nice
no it'll be horrible it'll to get
through those points did I get six
points yeah to get through those points
I'm guessing that that fifth degree
polynomial the perfect fit is an example
that occurs to practically everybody of
overfitting because do that making that
decision
perfect fit learn that learn the data
training data exactly we'll send the
polynomial I don't know what it looks
like
I don't want well I do want to know but
not right now anyway craziness and of
course I'm going to ask like that
probably I'm gonna ask you to plot the
results well what's the least squares
error when you fit by a straight line
when you fit when you fit by horizontal
line a constant fit by a straight line
move up to parabolas move up to cubics
but when you hit the hit this you're not
making any error at all you know you're
not really needing to use these squares
you could solve ax equal B a C will be
equals B so these this is the B thing
and C is the vector of of coefficients
and the matrix a is bad news when it's
6x6 when you get up to a complete fit
and I guess what I want to just to see
is a lot of things I don't know like
suppose I change 6 to 20 or something
then I'm pretty sure that not out out
there at 18 19 20 this thing is really
off the map and you could you could
compute its max and and you'd see a very
big number
but I don't know where but of course for
a straight line that would be pretty
safe the slope would be pretty moderate
and I don't know where are you so so
that's probably under fitting to try to
fit this by a straight line it's it's
not as close as you would want but
fitting by a full perfect fitting high
degree polynomial is certainly
overfitting where where is the boundary
I'm sure people know about this but I
think it is something we could learn
from so that's what that model one is
about and just to make one final comment
that matrix a has a name in the case
where you're where it's a square matrix
where you're fitting exactly
interpolating I would be the word so
there so that exact fit that corresponds
to square matrix a and the word for it
is interpolation and I guess it's like
wrong again seeing that guy too often
here so it'd be like groans
interpolation but the matrix has a
different name and whose name is
associated with that matrix vandermonde
vandermonde so this is the square matrix
which was so let me write it this is
called a vandermonde matrix and and it's
the matrix that has a crazy large
inverse because just as I'm saying the
see that comes out from the perfect fit
from the interpolation from the square
matrix the C is going to be giant and so
you
you could right you'll be able to you
you you will construct a matrix of
course to do this and it will be
identical to the vendor so we've heard
this word vandermonde matrix in this
class within the last week
anybody remember where the word
vandermonde came up in class it was in
professor Townsend's lecture so you
could go back to that video if you
wanted as an example of matrix which
which had a horrible inverse a giant
matrix the Hilbert matrix was another
example I think he did two examples
vandermonde and Hilbert so ventless
vandermonde matrix i could write it down
but you'll leave that to you has a big
inverse and it's its eigenvalues what no
singular values because it's not
symmetric its singular values are way
scattered you know it has tiny little
singular values plus an ordinary size
singular values so that's the example
that I just think you could go with and
as far as I can see you sending it to
autograder as a Julia file it'll be even
worse than usual sending it to
autograder
they won't I think it wouldn't know what
to do as far as I can see so I'm
thinking of some submissions to coming
to grade scope and I'm thinking of some
plots to show what happens as K
increases and some tables of data maybe
and then maybe a paragraph of of
conclusion like how what degree is safe
and when does it become risky and when
does it become disaster so stuff like
that that's it's really these are sort
of open-ended labs and and you use any
language
questions about that example which is
really that's what I'm expecting to to
be ready and and and quite quite a good
example for Wednesday after the break
what question are anyway you could even
email me you probably see they could see
what what that model looks like then
second one I've taken the first jump
into networks made a very simple network
without a lot of without any hidden
layers at all actually and just wrote
down what I think might work but you may
find that you want to modify model to go
for it I I don't have any patent or
personal stake in the way model two is
written but the idea is fit data and
we'll start with data but don't make it
too perfect because we don't want we
want some learning to happen here and so
so it's the classification problem so it
won't be least squares with a with it
with variables like U and V and W it's
just plus 1 or minus 1 or 1 0 or cat and
dog whatever the classification is so
that's the basic basic problem to start
with in deep learning to for quite a
long time that's the natural problem so
it's a classification problem and the
description here suggests one way to set
up the training data and and execute a
neural net like experiment by
- but without getting very far away from
ordinary - linear algebra yeah so you if
you want as I say if you wanted to
change this develop it further get some
ideas about it that's what that's what
the whole point is here
actually the faculty meeting on this
week maybe today what's today Wednesday
yeah so it's this afternoon no faculty
doesn't come to much but because it's
late in the afternoon but faculty
meeting this afternoon is about MIT
plans for requirements or courses in
computational thinking and in a way this
course within the math department is
among the ones that are in that
direction of course in other departments
those are further along anyway when
rajarao taught the course last spring he
had the Julia system better developed
and and there was a chance to bring
computers and bring laptops and do do
things in class and and you'll have that
chance again when he visits in in a
month ok enough and and I'm open to
questions about the project should I
maybe ask you to email me a rough idea
of a project and tell me if you were in
a group or if you would like to find a
group of maybe two or three people I'm
not thinking of groups of fifty two or
three would be sensible questions about
projects I mean I just introduced this
idea of our project
and I apologize for it not the food not
doing it that not bringing it up the
first week but I just couldn't see I
don't want to do exams on linear algebra
we passed that point so this seemed the
right way to go but I'm not you know I'm
not looking for a PhD thesis here
questions thoughts I guess I hope you
know you can ask oh good right how will
I I think yeah so the scope is connected
to the time that you would devote to it
and what should I say about scope maybe
the equivalent of three homeworks or
something because I'll all tamp down
homework says project date gets closer
does I give an idea that you know it's
it's so it's not not infinite but it's
not something tiny and trivial yeah good
well that's the thing there aren't
really past years we are though we are
the ones so so we I will have next year
if you contribute some good ideas maybe
I should should I ask
press or out maybe send us the projects
he uses in Michigan that would be some
ideas but remember that he does it
hasn't up to now anyway moved the course
toward deep learning he did other topics
all of which would be fine but then some
quite a few people have had some 603 six
or know something about convolutional
neural net
and I'm certainly excited to get to that
topic so the project could get there or
it could not both both totally fine okay
that's a good idea I'll ask Raj for just
the projects and you'll recognize a
couple because you've done a couple but
they're a bunch more yeah yeah then
there was another question and I'm
remembering that that there was I think
maybe everybody got an email or a
stellar announcement that that some
members of the class took an initiative
which was wonderful to open the
possibility of people just showing up
one evening a week in the Media Lab was
it or did it was a location and has it
happened or is it a future event it
happened okay
and but people I hadn't mentioned it in
class so probably you didn't have and
were not really into projects yet so
what it was probably a quiet evening
yeah yeah and that's productive but
quiet okay
so will it happen again after spring
break
okay so post again on stellar plan for
the next meeting that people could come
to yeah so this is David and her turn up
whoo so you'll recognize his name in
there and you did you have the meeting
in the Media Lab or okay okay so with
the break coming and spring hopefully
coming after today's potential storm
yeah when we come back good okay is that
good I hope some of that is helpful you
get an idea you're seeing about as much
as I know which is model one is
definitely do
and very significant and vandermonde
matrix ease and so on are truly
important and their instability is a big
issue but then moving toward weights and
and training data and test data is where
we want to go good ok so do I have some
time I do just to speak about mean and
variance the two golden words of
Statistics and covariance the matrix the
the intersection of linear algebra with
statistics and then some famous
inequality so this I'll continue with
this on Friday and post some of the
material so that's coming from a later
section of notes okay can I just talk
about so I either have probabilities P 1
up to P n adding to 1 or I have a
continuous distribution of probabilities
maybe from all X's from minus infinity
to infinity again giving 1 let me work
with the discrete example that's where
people naturally start so I have so what
is the mean so I I've been possible
outcomes with those probabilities and I
can either I can ask you about the
sample mean or I can ask you about the
expected mean okay so the sample means
we've done an experiment we've got some
output the expected mean means we know
probabilities but we haven't used them
yet
so those are
this is this uses actual output and the
sample mean is simply let me shall I
just say em for me well these two are
importantly different one is data is
something where you've done the
experiment and this is before you do the
experiment and the letters get maybe Mew
I've changed to Mew I don't want to use
s because s gets used with variance okay
so so it's just the average average
output from the sample so like I flipped
a coin a million times and the output
was 0 or 1 so I got a million ones and
zeros and I take the average and I'm
expecting a number like half a million
because I'm thinking of a fair coin so
that and the law of large numbers would
say that that that this sample mean does
approach 1/2 with probability 1 as the
number of samples gets larger so sample
mean is straightforward the expected
mean means we these are actual out
sample outputs they happened whereas the
expected mean is just the and I'll use
em for that it's it's the probability of
the first output times that output plus
the probability of the second output
times that output plus plus P and X okay
so it's the that will approach that with
probability 1 as this this number
capital n notice the difference capital
n here is the number of sample
the number of trials and it gets big
it's we keep doing things more and more
this is just this little n is the number
of possible different outputs with their
probabilities and there you see it and
of course in the continuous case we
would take the integral of X P of X DX
so let me just by analogy you should
know what the continuous version is and
what the discrete version is ok that's
the mean okay now for variance sample
variance and shall I say expected
variance I don't know just variance it's
what people would usually say I don't
know if I remember the right word there
sample variance what is that I included
this topic in the linear algebra book
anyway
yeah okay so what's the sample variance
so why I guess I'm yeah so what is the
sample variance what's the variance
about anyway what's the key point of
variance it's the distance from the mean
so will be this will be a distance from
the sample mean and this will be a
distance from the expected mean so not
distance from zero but distance from mu
and M from the center of the thing okay
so the sample variance so again we have
n samples but for some wonderful reason
in statistics you divide by n minus one
this time and the reason has to do with
the fact that you used one this will
involve the me mean so this would be the
this would be the first output minus mu
squared up to the nth output minus view
squared so it's the average distance
from you average squared distance from
you but with this little twist that of
course when n is large it's not a very
significant difference between n and n
minus one I think that's about right
all this is that I'm just doing one
experiment over and over covariance
which is the deeper idea is where linear
algebra comes in I have a matrix because
why because I'm doing several multiple
experiments at the same time I'm
flipping two coins I'm flipping fifteen
coins I'm doing other things so so that
will be covariances when I'm doing
several experiments at once that will
involve matrices of that size here so
what's the what's the variance I should
have given you the usual notation the
expected value of x that's what's the
mean and here I'm looking at the
expected value of what so when I'm
computing a variance using probabilities
so I'm using expectations not-not-not
trial runs expectations means use the
probabilities and what's the expectation
of the distance from X to the mean
square okay and that is when I what I'm
doing an expectation for for a discrete
set I think of the probability the first
probability that goes with an output x1
and a second probability that goes with
an output x2 and each time I subtract
from the mean and square okay so that's
the variance that everybody calls Sigma
squared
okay now two minutes left
is it is enough to say two to a few more
words about covariance over to get to
covariance I really have to speak about
joint probabilities that's a creaky idea
joint probabilities so I'm doing two
experiments at once so each one has its
own probabilities but together I have to
ask you know so here here are two easy
cases suppose I'm flipping two coins so
that I might get heads heads I may get
heads tails tails heads or tails tails
for possibility for possible outputs
there for possible pairs okay and if I
if you're flipping one coin and I'm
flipping another one those are
independent results those are
independent results there there won't be
a covariance where where some where
where by knowing what my flip was I
would know more about your flip but now
the other possibility would be to glue
the coins together now if I do a flip
they always come up heads and heads or
tails and Tails so the heads tails
combination is not possible in fact one
output is totally dependent on the other
output so that's the other extreme we
have independent outputs with covariance
0 and we have totally dependent outputs
one of the things are just glued
together when one result tells us what
the other result is then that situation
where the
the covariance is a maximum couldn't be
bigger than that and they say in polling
if you were pulling a family say
political polling well there would be it
there would be some covariance expected
there the two or three or five people
that you living in the same house
wouldn't be independent entirely
independent but they nor would they
always say all five give the same answer
so the covariance matrix would be have
some off-diagonal but it would it would
still be not invertible and actually
what i want to tell you about next time
at the start is that covariance matrix
which i have to define for you would be
will be symmetric positive definite or
or semi definite what's the semi
definite case of course that's the case
where the coins are glued together yeah
yeah okay thanks that's that's so you
know what's coming Friday I know that
holiday is also coming Friday and just
you'll make a good plan and I'll move on
after the break good